a quick question just about uh politics
you guys have been you guys have
spacewalked as so many visitors to the
station do and you see Earth and that
Earth does not have color-coded
boundaries of countries and so this
overview effect which so much is written
about can space be something that leads
all peace movements on Earth we both
have been fortunate enough to experience
that overview Effect one thing that
we've learned is that you know we get
the question a lot to politics on Earth
inform the way that you do your job on
here with an International Community and
I like to flip it around and say that
the way we do things up here actually
can inform our politics on Earth so I
think we do see this as an example of
how we can work together for the greater
good for greater humanity and the fact
that we are more alike than we are
different and we all have the same goals
you know at Our Roots